tu vas toucher énormément d'argent comme
Benjamin est-ce que tu veux t'éclater
pendant 15 ans avec une vie de fou ou
est-ce que tu veux faire 40 ans à
l'usine les gens ils vont dire je veux
la vie de Benjamin parce que tu pouvais
pas savoir normalement
tu dois comprendre que quand tu fais ce
métier là
ça va s'arrêter
maman difficile de Chavanne
tu te trompes
parce que j'ai moins travaillé que ce
que j'ai dévissé c'est pas du tout à
côté non non c'est parce que quand j'ai
voulu vendre les choses que je pensais
avoir acheté à mon âme et conscience et
de qualité et c'était de la merde donc
c'est très difficile
je me fais aucun cadeau mais si j'avais
pas des [ __ ] qui m'avait pluie qui
piqué mon l'oseille j'en ai rien encore
deux ou trois devant moi excusez-moi
qui le connais extrêmement bien le
problème c'est qu'il recommencera à
chaque fois
alors qu'il a rien
en euros et on dépense 2 mais c'est pour
ça que je la délai mais moi c'est pour
ça que j'aime ce mec toujours que c'est
vrai si c'est on sait pas Benjamin
Benjamin on le veut on veut Benjamin
Benjamin Benjamin
c'est relou et je peux dire cet été il
est en hélicoptère merde qu'est-ce que
tu fous maintenant c'était pas un
hélicoptère
c'est pas vraiment ça
moi j'aime beaucoup Benjamin mais je
soutiens texte entièrement parce que non
mais franchement Benjamin là vous êtes
non mais vous rigolez mais vous n'avez
pas retenu la leçon vous avez des
questions
visionnaires économiste
[Applaudissements]
effectivement j'ai toujours préféré
rouler en Ferrari
peut-être que vous avez vécu dans un
milieu mais je suis né le cul dans le
beurre
[Applaudissements]
on me dit il aura une chronique contre
lui sur France Inter